sin duda quienes han liderado las
protestas desde que se conoció el
fallecimiento de esta joven curda de 22
años maxa que había sido capturada por
la policía de la moral ha sido la gente
joven entre 17 18 19 años mujeres pero
también hombres que han salido a la
calle sin embargo estas protestas han
dado un giro en la última semana cuando
se reabrieron nuevamente las
universidades y los colegios que en Irán
empiezan con la llegada del otoño
Entonces no solamente Vimos una huelga
general en todo el país liderada por las
universidades sino que hemos visto como
decenas de niñas en los Colegios se han
quitado el velo aunque han cantado
eslóganes incluso han quebrado las fotos
que hay en cada salón donde está el
ayatolá alijame y el líder supremo de la
Revolución y también el creador de esa
República islámica el ayatola El Limón
ha sido interesante porque ellas mismas
se han ido enfrentando a los
representantes del estado que vienen a
convencerlas de utilizar es ese velo y
también hemos visto pues protestas a las
entradas y en todas las universidades
del país o en una de las en la mayoría
de ellas a lo largo de la nación iraní
sin embargo lo que más le ha dolido a la
población fue la represión que vivieron
los estudiantes de la universidad
shariff que es la universidad más
importante donde van los estudiantes con
mejores notas en los exámenes después de
graduarse del colegio es considerada la
universidad de los genios del país que
fueron reprimidos decenas de ellos
fueron capturados fueron incluso
amenazados muy fuerte por las
autoridades incluso por el ministro que
estuvo allí y hoy el debate dentro de
las autoridades es que hacer con esos
jóvenes con quien no tienen ninguna
diálogo han perdido toda conexión para
saber ellos que realmente quieren